Dr. Muhammad Gulam Mustafa
opthromologist from India. Sir, what is
the reason both scientifically and
spiritually to make halal chicken, halal
goat but not fish? Please reply. What
Dr. Muhammad Gula may be asking that
when we slaughter the chicken or the
goat, we do zabiha. So why is there not
requirement to do zabha to a fish? And
that's a very good question. As far as
Islam is concerned, Quran clearly
mentions in surah Maida chapter number 5
verse number 96 that lawful for you is
the pursuit of the water gain. And Allah
says in surah Maida, lawful for you a
food of the sea, fresh and tender. So
Allah has given permission. It's
allowed. And there are various hadith
that also says that amongst the dead
animal the only two that are permitted
it is the fish and the locust. So
there's hadith and only blood that is
permitted is that of the spleen and the
liver. So Islamically it is permitted to
have fish without doing zabya. But we
know Islamically whether goat, chicken
or cow etc when we have to eat them we
have to slaughter dujal to zabya. In
zabya what we do there are various
conditions the main is that see to it
that the knife is sharp. See to it that
it's not in front of other good and you
do it swiftly and once you slaughter the
windpipe and the veins and the jagular
veins and the artery when you do it you
leave it you leave the animal the animal
will rhyth and the blood will flow out
of the animal. So when you do zabiha the
blood which is a good media of germs and
bacteria majority flows out of the body.
So that's the reason zabya is compulsory
when we are having non-veg food like
like uh meat, mutton, beef etc. Anything
we have to do zabya. This is the
scientific so that the blood flows out
of the body. When the blood flows out of
the animals body there are less germs
and bacterias because blood is a very
good medium of germs and bacteria. So it
keeps the mutton or the chicken fresh
for longer time. If you have slaughtered
by the Islamic method of zabya a goat or
a sheep or a cow or a chicken it will
stay for a longer time because blood is
a very good media of germs and bacteria.
So in the normal cases that if you don't
do zabya the blood remains in the body
of the animal and even the disease
remains and high chances of you getting
the disease. So Islamic slaughtering
zabya is a must for non-weed. Now the
question posed is why not zabya for
fish? Because fish is sea life and goat
and sheep they are animals. They don't
live in water. The difference in the
system is that in the fish there are
gills and when the fish dies it gasps.
when it gaps the gills it sucks all the
blood into the gills. So in a fish when
a fish dies when a fish is bought
outside water it struggles and you find
it withering and then it dies. So when
it's out of water because the fish
cannot breathe. So what happens when it
starts breathing and it cannot it so it
it can only normally breathe in water.
It doesn't have the function to breathe
a normal air like of human animals have.
So what happens most of the blood is
sucked by the gills. So when a fish has
died because of loss of air loss of
oxygen when it dies the blood is sucked
by the gills. That's the reason the
scientifically the blood doesn't remain
in the body of the fish. Number one, the
blood of the fish differs from the blood
of the goat, the sheep or the animal.
It's not as much of bacteria and toxins
as the blood of the goat, the cow, the
sheep. And secondly, the blood is
sucked. So first of all, this blood is
not as dangerous as the blood of the
animals. Number two, the blood is
sucked. Because the blood is sucked, the
germs and bacteria are not there. So
eating the fish is safe. This is the
scientific reason. Hope that answers the
question.